this is the most insane thing
I have ever seen we'll see and it will
never end
this is a Civics poll showing the
national economy's current condition
right now this polling represents how
Democrats feel about the economy that's
a national election National National
economy current condition 49 of
democratic voters believe the economy is
fairly good
only 37 think it's bad 26 a fairly bad
11s say very bad seven are unsure and
seven think it's very good
seven percent of Democrats think the
economy is very good okay we'll find
it's low right but
how could anyone think the economy right
now is in any way good these people
they're an occult they are zombies
there's no way you go to the grocery
store and there's no eggs and there's no
milk and you're like everything's great
Nicole I wish that they did some
follow-up questions on like what markers
are you using to say it's fairly good
well take a look at this Republicans
you've got only four percent of
Republicans saying fairly good less than
a percent say very good 68 say very bad
and they are objectively correct that a
carton of eggs is six bucks in some
places it's four four eighty up to six
bucks that is objectively bad now here's
the best part you look at independent
voters they mostly agree with
Republicans that it's very bad or fairly
bad but about 21 of Independents think
it's fairly good that's because around
21 of Independence probably lean
Democrat but my point with this is
consistently we see the voter base that
Republicans need to win side with
Republicans in their world view and
that's good news the bad news is
Democrats are deranged completely and I
don't know how you save them from
themselves there's a significant portion
of the population that refuse to
acknowledge reality because they hate
the reality that that's going on around
them they don't they don't want Joe
Biden to be a bad president and so so
they're they refuse to acknowledge the
things that Joe Biden has done that were
bad policy and this isn't anything about
Joe Biden as a there none of this is
personal attack this is it would be the
same no matter who the Democrat
candidate is because it's Democrat
policy it's policies that the Democrats
and the left want Joe Biden is a rubber
stamp the man is empty as it gets
because he's he's barely awake when he's
doing things at work uh so this is it's
it's just that the the left does not
want to admit that the policies are not
working you can't have DA's release
criminals after they've been arrested
and expect them to not continue to
commit crime you cannot endlessly print
money and expect there to be no
inflation these things are not in the
control under the control of human
beings like no government has ever been
able to control these types of things
it's ridiculous
you know I'm concerned a little bit
about the electric you know Tammy
mentioned about the independence and we
thought The Independents were going to
do very well for us here in the midterms
here and and you know we only won the
house by what we got a five-seat
majority we thought we were going to do
much much better but I think that's
because of ballot harvesting yeah I
think that the American people I maybe
have short memories I don't know if it's
the ill in form the uninformed voter
this and that but when when you look at
our our economy today whether it's the
inflation the few prices what's
happening globally with Ukraine and and
all the other stuff China uh and and
crime the southern border under Donald
Trump we didn't have these issues we
have a crisis on every corner in America
today Troy not for nothing but the the
Republicans are the Republicans
responsible it's their responsibility to
get elected the reality is on the ground
have to be brought to the population in
a way that they can understand and see
it that motivates them to get to the
polls to vote and they have Republicans
are responsible for doing that so I mean
it's you're right about everything all
the the it's it's not getting into the
polls it's bringing the polls well fair
enough fair enough this is look
you uh you guys use win red
win red is the online fundraising system
that Republicans use and how how many
years did it take for Republicans to
figure that out Democrats had act blew
up for like I think three years before
Republicans finally figured out how to
take online donations so Democrats are
consistently ahead of Republicans in
figuring how to game the system to win
better they did it with Obama and social
media they did it with win with uh with
uh act blue and then you know
Republicans were late with win red and
now you have ballot harvesting and all
the rule changes that were implemented
and the best Republicans would muster up
was you shouldn't be doing that while
the Democrats did it and then did it
again so they they win through Universal
mail-in voting and ballot harvesting
then 2022 comes around and they double
down and do it more and the best we got
from Republicans both times was oh I'm
wagging my finger at you for doing that
what should have happened is as soon as
2020 was over there should have been an
assessment where they were like how did
here's the problem
so many of trump supporters believed
there's there's no way Biden could get
these votes it's impossible therefore it
must be fraud and I'm sitting here like
or they created Universal mail and
voting they sent the ballots to people's
homes everybody was talking about it and
instead of people realizing that if you
knock on someone's door and say hey
that's that thing right there fill that
out I'll take it from you and if you
don't I'll be back tomorrow instead of
believing that's how easy it was they
believed that China was sending in fake
ballots that people were duplicating it
now I'm sure there are probably
instances of people like a mom gets like
three ballots and then she fills them
out for her kids because there was that
lady on the was it on The View she
claimed to have done that she's like I
voted for my son and it was like like
nobody cared and she's not gonna go to
jail or anything like that but the
reality was
you it's easy to mobilize activists in
cities
you go to one building in Manhattan and
you can knock on enough doors to talk to
one thousand people by the end of the
day but a rural area you cannot do that
and so not only Republicans not focused
on ballot collection harvesting and
chasing but they didn't even realize
that before this ground game in cities
is easier so moving into 2024 I think
that's why I think Trump said this we're
going to become about harvesting
Powerhouse and all Republicans are now
realizing like oh wait maybe that's why
we lost the example is Orange County
California traditionally Republican one
day all of a sudden votes Democrat and
everyone's like what how did that happen
the Republican party down there says hey
they're doing ballot harvesting the next
election the Republicans won so I think
the the mood of the nation is correct
regular people independent voters
conservatives Libertarians the freedom
faction we're going to call it people
who aren't in the world cult know it's
bad and are pissed off and they would
prefer Donald Trump or at least not a
Biden
but with ballot harvesting you got
people who are in their apartment
sitting there playing video games not
comes on their door and they're like
look man I don't know anything about
that politics stuff and they'll go well
why don't you fill out that fill that
out right there it's like all right what
do I just sign it there you go man have
a good day that works so if Republicans
get on that it's going to go back to
normal it's infuriating that that's
that's legal but if that's what we have
to do that's that's a chance 26 States I
think it's legal yeah some states have
specific restrictions on how you do it
unbelievable but I think there's like 13
states where you can just knock on doors
and take belts and and people who are
like shocked to find that in some swing
States you can go to a nursing home with
a ballot for every person or go to the
nursing home ask the nursing home staff
to collect all the mail-in ballots that
were delivered there then have all the
elderly people come into the room and
say I'm gonna I'm gonna deliver your
votes for you so why don't you all fill
it out and sign put my name on it I'll
sign it and then I'm allowed to drop
your votes off for you and all these old
people go thank you for visiting
people don't get it it's that easy so
Republicans got to get on that game and
then they'll win
so do you think Republicans are ready
for that going into 2024 I mean have a
republican Scott Pressler is out there
working his fingers to the Bone and they
disrespect this guy they need to put him
in charge of like the rnc's Outreach or
whatever
get him on on on this program he'll take
care of it for all of you guys is that
what the issue was with Carrie Lake I
don't know if that was the issue of
Carrie like I think Carrie Lake was
saying that a lot of these polling
locations that that were mostly uh in
areas where it was strongly Conservative
Republican you know had issues either
with the with the voting machines or
they were running out of paper they had
issues with the ballots so I think it's
a multi-faceted it's it's all sorts of
issues the Democrats have been better at
it I think the Democrats have become
very good at cheating and once that's
what they do they cheat I'm not saying
that we got to get better at cheating
but we have to get some Integrity back
into our electoral process our process
of of Elections and I I think it would
be very simple we should just have one
day there's no reason we need to have
two three weeks I agree we should have
one day of voting you know and as
Afghanistan you put the little uh you
put the little ink on the finger and you
put it on the ballot you know it stayed
there for three days we know if you
voted before you know you can't bring a
different finger back and I just think
we've got to cut down to one day and and
hit paper ballots get rid of the
machines paper ballots one day making a
national holiday agreed France can do it
these other countries do it was it like
France they have like a glass box and
you walk up and put it in there's people
watching from different parties and they
watch it all happen it's that simple
yeah but I agree with you the Democrats
are very very good at cheating and
Republicans suck at it but let's define
what cheating is they go to the state
legislatures and they change the rules
to favor themselves they Implement
Universal mail-in voting to favor
themselves all of these things were done
through a legal process now in many
instances these processes were
challenged and their allies in the court
said no everything's fine thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time